you did a very funny stand-up special
where you just it was made just because
you are a musician your drummer yes and
you made a stand-up special that was
specifically for drummers yeah and it
was it was filled with jokes and
observations that drummers would
appreciate yes hey it was James worm
worth was loved it he loved every second
yeah I did the stand-up special that was
just every joke was about drum equipment
and drum hardware I'll give you an
example yeah what about this was
beautyrx I didn't do this I'll do this
gracefully I don't want to go I don't
want to do a Norma's in yeah nicely yeah
there you go so one of the things I
discussed is that when drummers go
shopping for cymbals they act as in a
drum shop there's all these cymbals it's
like trees of cymbals and drummers go
around trying them out kind of like fine
wine like
and then as a drummer so that was one
joke look at him exactly he's talking
about just face you the whole time yeah
yeah and then the other thing is I spent
many years as a drummer and my memory of
being a drummer is less about like being
in front of an audience and playing and
amps and stuff like that my experience
is mostly China undo the screw of of a
cymbal stand and then it always falls
off then I have to go get it and then
the other thing would be number two
right yes yes that's the second job and
then the other one was when non drummers
by the way are there any drummers in
this audience great so you got this is
great all right so the other thing is
when making three people happy yes the
other thing is when whenever
non drummers try to help you are there
there yes undo your undo your kit yeah
they always do it wrong so they sort of
hand you
thank you very much that's it
Thanks thank you thank you very much
but you notice it's not just about
drummers you've notice things about
other musicians as well yeah I'm trying
to work on some other instruments look
at you're trying to move be up and
beyond the hammer yes and here you go
this is the guitar and but you're a
guitar player so you are yeah yeah so
when people take out a guitar one thing
I noticed one thing that bums me out I
don't know if this ever affects you guys
but like every see when people start
playing this is this always seems like
bad news to me I just don't want to hear
the rest of the song they're muffling it
yeah they're making a pose or just sort
of our sort of bluesy there's something
about the blues that I'm like oh here
comes a long song yeah and then jazz
jazz guitar players hey yeah
Jimmy Vivino is loving all of this yeah
I love it yeah jazz musicians I don't
like that they take songs that we know
and recognize and just by changing the
chords they just make it their own sort
of like put it's bended 9th in there
isn't that cool
no give me jingle bells that's fantastic
I like that you got me all right good
I'll see if I can hold you let's see if
I can keep you you can hold me anytime
you are ok so then you have you guys
never got into a show where there's
there's a political band right very
political and the lead singer is going
on a political rant so I'm gonna do the
guitar player in that band sometimes
they're there playing and they have to
stop this is my impression of I guess
our play has got to stop
while this singer goes on a rant so it's
it's mid song
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
you